SIRI CHERUKURI:
Winter is coming.
Which means we must
always be one and have
constant vigilance.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes, we need
to build our walls to keep DDoS
attacks and data hackers out.
So how do I keep my dragons--
or better yet, people--
in check from releasing
confidential data?
SIRI CHERUKURI: Mobile
Dragon Management, duh.
Or in Google's terms, Mobile
Device Management for G Suite.
STEPHANIE WONG: I think
we need to see a demo.
SIRI CHERUKURI: All
right, let's jump into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is how the G Suite
Admin Console looks like.
First, you need to set up
the Apple Push Notification
Certificate in the console
to establish a connection
to the Apple Push
Notification Service,
which is popularly
called the APNS service,
so that G Suite MDM--
or any other MDM,
for that matter--
can efficiently send commands
to all your managed iOS device
feed.
To set it up, you download a
certificate signing request
from the console, upload it
into the Apple Push Certificate
Portal by logging in
with your Apple ID.
You will then receive a
signed certificate from Apple.
Download that signed
certificate, and upload it
back in the G Suite
Admin Console here.
You are now ready to roll.
You can enable MDM
in the setup, and can
choose if each device
that is being enrolled
needs to be approved by an admin
before it gets the settings.
You can set up password
policies, be it basic,
standard, or strong.
You also have some additional
settings on the device
that you can control, like
you can pick if notifications
are allowed to be viewed
on the lock screen
and if you want
managed apps to be
able to sync using mobile data.
Or if you want the user
to be able to back up
the device with iCloud,
some Safari settings,
and some specific settings
are on photos, screen capture,
and Siri.
Now, once you as an admin
have decided and applied
all the settings you want
to enforce on these devices,
you just have to turn
on device management,
send out communications
to your employees
to start enrolling
their devices.
Now, let's see what the
user experience looks like.
So this is my iPad.
I have my personal Gmail on it.
To enroll a device,
you first have
to download the Google Device
Policy App from the App Store.
And then, once it downloads,
you log in with G Suite account.
This is my super
secret password.
Accept the terms and conditions,
and install the profile.
This is the G Suite MDM profile.
It takes a bit.
At this point, if you are
required admin approval,
the user won't see anything till
the admin approves this device.
I've set it up for
automatic approval, though,
so it's pretty instant.
We need to put in our password
one more time to sync email.
It has synced mail,
contacts, and calendar
here in the native mailer.
Now, let's go
check out our mail.
There's two accounts here--
my personal Gmail, and
the G Suite work account.
Now, let's say I
lost this device.
The G Suite admin can simply
wipe my corporate email
from the console
sitting in his office,
and ensure that all
the work data is safe.
He has the device,
we just enroll.
Since this is my
personal device,
I'll only have the admin
wipe my work email,
and leave everything
is on there.
If it's a corporate
device, we can potentially
wipe the whole device, too.
The comment has been sent.
Going back to the
device, you can
see that there's only
one account now--
my personal one.
That's it.
It's as simple as that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow,
that was pretty amazing.
For sure we're going to win
the throne with that one.
SIRI CHERUKURI: If
only winning thrones
was as easy as mobile device
management with Google Cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: If you want
to get in touch with us,
go ahead and click
on the link below.
SIRI CHERUKURI: And if you
like what you saw today,
please like, share,
and subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]